we are inching ever closer to the final
episode of this series for breath of the
wild before we jump ship to the sequel
if you still continue to follow this
series we appreciate you sticking around
for this many episodes it means a lot to
us without further Ado here we go
normally every time you throw a
boomerang it swings around to the left
side well for some reason if you want to
switch directions just hop to the right
as you throw and it'll swing around to
the right side with you instead
before I've shown how you can get some
interesting interactions with traveling
NPCs when attacked by certain enemies
but did you know that most of them are
specifically terrified of Guardians
even in some areas that are impossible
for Guardians to reach in normal
gameplay such as the Truffle sisters
next to Foothill stable or even Dilly
and Jorah way out in the middle of the
Gerudo desert bringing a guardian to
them will have them react accordingly in
conversation
some players still haven't seen all of
the zero stamina charge attacks with
each major weapon type sword two handers
and Spears they have a unique animation
when you're out of stamina
players were asking last episode how I
was able to drop the master sword well
along with the other complex glitches
IST and WMC found last year which we
have videos on another sub glitch even
more complex called hold prompt
entanglement was found allowing players
to hold and eat anything in Link's
inventory this has many applications but
just a couple of them are dropping the
master sword holding items into
Overworld normally impossible eating
anything you own including korok seeds
or even eating durability off of armor
which changes its color
[Music]
in hateno Village many colored Banners
are scattered about the town likely died
by sage and some of these banners can be
walked under the interesting thing is
that the game's lighting changes
accordingly when you hang out underneath
them such as purplish tint here and this
reddish tint here there are very few
locations in the game that do this but
once you see it it's pretty hard to miss
here's some simple and super hidden
details about the korok forest these
three silent princesses are placed in
this way around the Master Sword to
match the small flowers and a link to
the past as well as a tree trunk you
initially walk through to reach the
center of the woods there's an extremely
subtle secret in the Lost Woods that's
easy to miss the initial torchlet path
leading to the middle of the woods is a
reference to Zelda 1. the secret
directions for north
West
South
once you reach the center of the woods
you're on your own and the Easter egg
ends you can see this pathing on the
breath of the wild object map there's a
special evolving conversation that only
cannelli or Bluto will do but not king
dorofon or reju the specific location of
the legendary Master Sword they both
initially start out pretty cryptic
saying that you should just start
looking for the master sword but for
every Divine Beast that you complete
they start getting a bit more specific
such as saying it sleeps in a forest at
two beasts specifically saying the Lost
Woods at three beasts and precisely
saying the Lost Woods west of here from
Pluto or east of here from canelli at
four Beast completed they likely
designed this so that it ensures that by
the time you've beaten four beasts late
in the game you have a pretty good idea
of where the master sword should be
there are many conversations in breath
of the wild that require short checks to
be completed before they're triggered
but some conversations in particular are
so specific that very few players have
come across these naturally this
conversation with Teba about Tulin
saying it's too rainy to take him to the
flight range is one of the rarest in the
game in order to trigger this you need
to First Complete bombetto second not
complete the recital at the warbler's
nest which for some reason permal locks
the weather in Rito Village to be sunny
Forever After completion third have it
rain in tabantha which out of every
weather RNG and Hyrule five percent is
the usual average lowest but Samantha
takes number one rarest weather at two
percent chance of rain fourth then
finally talk to Teba during daytime not
night time then you can finally hear
this interaction which I'm guessing very
few players have ever seen Rolla the
owner of the aeroshop in kakariko gives
a quick quest to light the Torches
around the goddess statue in the middle
of town but did you know that she will
react negatively or positively depending
on how you like them if you use fire
arrows or fire lit normal arrows she'll
appraise you for what a great shot you
were
but if you like them by any other means
she'll know and instead she'll be
disappointed in you for not following
directions and letting her down
here's a couple more location references
spectacle rock is a reference to the
same location in Zelda 1 and A Link to
the Past in Japanese it's simply called
glasses Rock but spectacle is of course
another word for glasses which this name
is wordplay of in this section east of
the gray Plateau the bridges are named
oulin horwell and egus along with bacho
Lake all of these characters are found
on skyloft in Skyward Sword and finally
Nabi and tetla Lake are references to
previous Zelda fairies Ocarina of times
Navi and Majora's Mask tattle and tail
both names which can be spelled out from
the letters in this name bonus fun fact
the Majora's Mask fairies names when
spoken aloud reads out tattletail
another word for a snitch did you know
that the antenna on Van Nabors back are
based off of the antenna on chica Towers
through the development of breath of the
wild one of the techniques they had in
creating new environments is to have one
of the developers take a snapshot of
undeveloped land then have an artist
bring it to Life by drawing over the
image then sending it back to the
developers to create the 3D model in the
Overworld
birds in particular Ducks might have an
animation that you may recognize when
shot out of the air not on the ground
they fall to the ground while spinning
this is a direct reference to a game you
definitely know Duck Hunt
has an E10 rated game breath of the wild
isn't particularly mature rated per se
but Nintendo did put some suggestive
details that push it just a tad just a
couple to mention are inputs spilling
the beans on where piya's birthmark is
[Music]
very questionable noises when picking
the spa option in Gerudo town and
talking to teva's son Tulin naked will
get him scared and calling for Mom
and maybe some players don't know still
but the upgraded sleeping option at the
four major Villages such as the gerudos
will have an extra sound effect
including the ritos down feather beds
the Zora's bouncy Blissful waterbeds
and the gorons questionable massage
honestly they all sound kind of
suspicious connecting gears and breath
of the wild aren't just set pieces for
display like most other games they are
fully working mechanical pieces acting
in real time so obviously besides using
stasis to pause the entire mechanism
since it freezes one piece actually
getting a large object jammed between
the gears will work just as well and
turn the mechanism off
[Music]
this is even more impressive when inside
the Champions ballad DLC dungeon where
one jammed shuts down the entire
machine because they're all
interconnected just another small reason
why breath of the Wild's engine is so
highly regarded
[Music]
what was your favorite thing you learned
this time let us know in the comments
below of course we'll keep going with
this series into tears of the Kingdom
where we'll continue to gather a bunch
of facts for you for everything else
though you know where to go right here
on Gamespot
thank you
foreign
[Music]